양자 컴퓨팅이 머신러닝을 개선할 수 있는 한 분야가 있어
바로 커널 함수나
커널 행렬과 관련된 건데, 그게 뭔지 한번 살펴보자
그러려면 세 가지를 다시 짚고 넘어가야 해
첫째, 왜 머신러닝에서 내적이 나오는 걸까
둘째, 왜 머신러닝 문제는 고차원을 다루는 걸까
그리고 커널 함수란 무엇인가
내적, 혹은 내부 곱은
실수 n차원 벡터 a와
b에 대해 a의 크기와
b의 크기의 곱에 두 벡터 사이의 각도 θ의 코사인을 곱한 거야
이건 a의 각 성분에 대응하는
b의 성분을 곱해서
더하는 것과 같아. 그리고 주목할 점은, 두 벡터가
거의 직교에 가까울 때, 예를 들어 a는
0에 가까운 성분을 갖고 b는 큰 성분을 가질 때
내적이 작아진다는 거야. 이건
θ가 π/2에 가까워지는 것과 같아
마찬가지로, a의 성분이 음수이고 b의
성분이 양수이면
두 벡터가
거의 반대 방향을 가리키는 거고
θ가 π에 가까울 때
내적 결과가
음수가 될 수 있어. 반대로 a도 크고 b도
같은 부호로 큰 성분을 가지면
두 벡터가 거의 평행해서 θ가 0에 가깝고
내적은 커지고
양수가 돼. 그러니까 내적이 데이터 포인트 간의
유사도를 측정하는 데 유용하다는 건
충분히 납득할 수 있는 거야. 모든 n차원 데이터가
n-1차원으로
쉽게 분리되는 건 아니야, 즉 선이나
평면, 초평면으로 말이야. 데이터가 n차원에서 잘 분리되지 않을 때
데이터 포인트를
더 높은 차원, 예를 들어 m차원으로 임베딩할 수 있어, m이
n보다 큰 경우. 이걸 특징 매핑이라고 해
보통 x를 φ(x)로 매핑하는 거로 나타내는데
φ(x)는 n차원 실수에서
m차원 실수로의 매핑이야
이게 가장 이해하기 쉬운 건
1차원 데이터를 2차원으로 구부려 올리거나
2차원 데이터를
3차원에 임베딩하는 경우야
하지만 현실에서는 수천 개의
심지어 수백만 차원의 공간에 데이터를 임베딩하는 경우도 많아
3차원 벡터의 내적과 2차원 벡터의 내적을 비교하면
그 차이는 거의 없지만
백만 차원 벡터의 내적은
완전히 손도 못 댈 수준이 돼
대규모 데이터셋에 적용하려면 말이야
그래서 사람들이 기발한 트릭을 생각해냈어
만약 고차원으로의 투영을
아주 특정한 형태로 쓴다면 어떨까
그렇게 하면 고차원에서의 벡터 내적이
저차원 벡터의
간단한 함수로 나타낼 수 있어. 즉, 데이터 x에서 고차원 φ(x)로의
매핑을 찾는 건데
특징 공간에서의 내적이
저차원 데이터에서의
간단한 함수로 주어지도록 말이야.
이 함수 k를 커널 함수라고 해
이상적으로는 이 커널 함수가
저차원
내적 자체의 함수가 되면 좋겠어. 그러면
두 마리 토끼를 다 잡을 수 있거든. 매우 고차원의 특징 공간이면서도
계산하기 쉬운 내적을 쓸 수 있는 거야
처음 보면 이게
과연 가능한 건지 불분명할 수도 있어. 아주 낮은 차원의
간단한 예를 하나 살펴보자
이 특정 특징 매핑을 생각해봐. a
3차원 벡터를
9차원 공간으로 매핑하는 거야. 알고 보면
9차원 특징 매핑된
공간의 내적은 단순히 원래
3차원 공간의 내적의 제곱으로 나와. 즉
φ 함수를 사용해 매핑된 공간의 내적은
각 벡터의
9개 좌표를 계산해야 해
첫 번째 벡터에 9개, 두 번째에
9개, 그리고 내적 자체는
9번의 곱셈과 합산이 필요하니
총 28번의 연산이 돼
커널 함수는 3번의 곱셈과
2번의 합산, 즉 총 4번의 연산만 필요해
이건 3차원 데이터 포인트를
9차원 특징 공간으로 매핑한 경우야
아주 큰 공간에서는 이게 엄청난 이점이 된다는 걸
쉽게 알 수 있지.
커널 함수는 보통 연속 함수여서
데이터셋의 어떤 벡터에도 적용할 수 있어
그런데 커널 함수는
데이터셋에서 데이터 포인트의 쌍을 가져와서
그 쌍을 인수로 사용해. 커널 함수를
데이터셋의 모든 쌍에 적용하면
커널 행렬이라 불리는 대칭 행렬이 만들어져
어떤 커널 함수를 쓸지는 문제에 따라 달라. 정리하자면
데이터셋에서 벡터의 유사도를 나타내려면
내적이 필요한데
아주 고차원 특징 공간에서의 내적은 비용이 많이 들어
그래서 특정 커널 함수에 대응하는
특징 매핑을 활용해
특수한 커널 함수를 쓰면
계산을 더 효율적으로 만들 수 있어
하지만 특수한 커널 함수로 제한하면
특징 공간으로의 매핑 방식이 제한될 수 있어
이러면
데이터를 잘 분리하지 못할 수도 있어
다른 방법이 있으면 얼마나 좋을까
바로 여기서 양자 컴퓨팅이 등장해
커널 함수에 대응하는 아주 고차원의 특징 매핑을
양자 컴퓨터에서 수행할 수 있어
양자 커널 추정기에서 커널 행렬 k가 계산되고
거기서부터 고전적인 머신러닝 알고리즘을
활용할 수 있어. 이렇게 하면 데이터 포인트 x1이
로딩되고 매핑된 다음
또 다른 x2가 로딩되고
매핑돼. 두 양자 상태의 내적이
측정 확률과 관련이 있으니까
두 매핑된 데이터 포인트의 내적을
결과 circuit을 충분히 많이 측정해서
추정할 수 있어. 이런 식으로 circuit이
내적에 대한 정보를 알려줄 수 있어
circuit이 모델링할 수 있는
어떤 고차원 공간에서든 말이야
내적이나 커널 함수를 고전적으로 직접 계산하지 않고도
이 방법들을 맞춤화하고 발전시키는
방법이 많이 있어
실제로 항상 새로운 방법들이 제안되고
테스트되고 있어. 이
개요가 틀을 잡는 데
양자 컴퓨팅의 적용에 대해
머신러닝 방법들에
특히 커널을 포함한 방법들에 도움이 됐으면 해